all of this
sir my rings madam modiano
jara at 4000 and the meurthe mid-november at
the 4th earth as it is at rex
new madness snail games camille and
our phaenic center implemented
long half is complex
1 min lee breuer sculptural anodyne
a big flame like study by name nos
regions where the nice regulators live
cannes will do besides I have a husband
violent centiliters are bios oberwil
not looking for my chilly time and
enhancement of factum melancholy have
interviews the text submitted to del neri
returning you will find the track
regret but what he really is a
big brother dynasty brad thorn do not have
course in the back order for lockerbie
mine and one click pelote lite live there
without this wall camarsac al-agha mark and
they are surprised to be more firm
signed in teak batman l'omsl home
e7 is at naples ide and burgundy and
9th art point m the pilot and destroy
servic high points advisors all
this debate will be milhas of their
communication will ask me for commands
at the end of May at night
please
I would like to tell you simply
how happy I am to be among
you and how much I am moved by the honor
you did not give me this
Nobel Prize in literature
this is the first time I have to
give a speech in front of a
large assembly
and I feel some
apprehension
we would be tempted to believe that for a
writer it is natural and easy to
deliver on this exercise but a writer
or at least a novelist often has
difficult relationships with speech
and if we remember this distinction
school between the written and the oral
a novelist is more talented for
creeks for the oral one he used to
keep quiet and if he wants to penetrate a
atmosphere it must blend into the
crowd he listens to conversations without
look and if he intervenes in
this one
it's always to ask a few
discrete questions in order to better
understand the women and men who
surround
he has a hesitant word because of his
usual erasures and his writings of course
after multiple erasures his style
may sound limpid but when he
speaks he no longer has the resource
to correct his hesitations
and then I belong to a generation where
we did not let the children speak
except on certain occasions without enough
rare and six ask for permission
but we do not listen to them so well that
often they were cut off
that explains the difficulty
speech of some of us
sometimes hesitant sometimes too fast like
if he feared every moment to be
interrupted from where undoubtedly this desire
to write that did not take as much
others at the end of childhood
you hope adults will read you
they will be obliged to listen to you
without interrupting you and they will know a
times for all you have on the
heart
the announcement of this prize seemed unreal and
I was anxious to know why you
I had chosen that day I believe
never felt so
how much a novelist is blind screwed to
from his own books and how much
voters know more than him
on what he writes a novelist can only
never be his reader except for
correct in his manuscript mistakes
of syntax repetitions or delete
a paragraph too much he only has one
confused and partial representation of
his books as a painter busy at
to make a ceiling mural and who
lying on a scaffolding work in
the details of too closely without vision
aggregate
curious lonely activity than that
to write you go through moments of
discouragement
when you write the first pages
of a novel you have every day
the impression of going astray
so what
if we are great to go back
and to take you on another path
do not succumb to this
temptation
but following the same road is a bit
like to be driving a car the
night in winter and ride on the ice
without any visibility you do not have
the choice
you can not go back
you must continue to advance in you
saying that the road will end up being
more stable and that the fog is
will dissipate about to complete a
book it seems to you that this one
starts to break away from you and he
already breathe the air of freedom like
children in the class the day before
summer holidays
they are distracted and noisy and
no longer listen to their teachers I
would even say that at the moment you write
the last paragraphs the book
shows some hostility in its
to free yourself from you and he leaves us
scarcely have you drawn the last
words it's over he does not need anymore
you have already forgotten you are these are the
readers now who will reveal it to
himself you are experiencing at that moment a
big empty and the feeling of having been
abandoned is also a kind
of dissatisfaction because of this link
between the book and you who has been sliced
too fast
this dissatisfaction and this feeling of
something unexplained is pushing to
write the next book to restore
balanced without you getting there
never as the years go by
books
succeed and readers will talk about the 9
may you feel that it does not
was you a tail of a long
flight forward
yes the reader years and longer than on
a book that its author himself himself
passes between a novel and his reader a
phenomenon analogous to that of
development of photos as it is
practiced before the digital era
at the time of drawing in the room
black
the picture gradually became visible
how far we advance in reading
of a novel
the same process takes place
chemicals but for there to be such
agreement between the author and his reader he
is necessary that the novelist does not force
never his reader in the sense that one dida
singer that he forces his voice but
drive him imperceptibly and he
leaves enough room for the
book impregnates it little by little and that by
an art that looks like acupuncture or
it is enough to peck the pointer a
very specific place and the flow that
spread in the nervous system
this intimate and complementary relationship
between the novelist his reader I believe
that we do not find the equivalent in
the musical field
I always thought that writing was
close to music
close to music but much less
pure that this one and I always envied
the musicians who feel me practices
is an art superior to novels and
poets who are closer to
musicians that novelists I
started writing poems in my
childhood and it's probably thanks to that
that I understood better
the reflection that I read somewhere
it is with a bad poet that one
does prose writers and then with regards
regards music
it's often for a novelist
to train all people
landscapes the streets he could observe
in a part in a partition
musical where we find the same
melodic fragments from one book to another
but a musical score that
will seem imperfect
there will be in the novelist the regret of
have not been a pure musicians and
did not compose the nocturnes of
chopin the world slips of lucidity from
Critical retreat of a novelist vis-à-vis
from all of his own books
also holds a phenomenon that I have
noticed in my case and in that of
many others
every new book time to write it
clears the previous
to the point that I have the impression of
to have forgotten it I thought I had
written one after the other
discontinuous way ac or oblivion
successive but often the same
faces the same names the same places
the same sentences come from one to
the other as the reasons for a
tapestry that would have been woven into a
half a half sleep sleep or a half
waking dream a novelist is often a
sleepwalker time they have penetrated
because he has to write and one can
fear that he will be crushed when he
crosses a street but we forget this
extreme precision of sleepwalkers who
walking on the roofs have never fallen
in the statement that followed
the announced of this nobel prize
I retained the following sentence that was
an allusion to the last war
world he unveiled the world of
the occupation I am like all those
and those born in 45 a child of war
and more specifically since I was born to
Paris
a child who owed what had to
birth in paris the occupation of
people who lived in this paris there
wanted to quickly forget about it or not
remember that daily detail of
those who give the illusion that after
the whole life of every day had not
been so different from the one they
normally led a bad dream
is also a vague remorse for having been
somehow survivors and
when their children questioned them
more later on this period and on
this paris there
their answer is elusive or else he
keep silent as if he wanted to
strike out of their existence
those dark years and hide us
Something
but in front of the silences of our parents
we all guessed as if we
had lived strange city that this paris
occupation
in appearance life go on as
before
the theaters the cinemas the halls
paul music the restaurants were
open
we could hear songs on the radio
were even in theaters and
cinemas a lot more people than before
war as if the elite these places
were shelters where people get
gather and squeeze each other
against others for reassurance but
unusual details indicated that paris
was not anymore
the same as before because of
the absence of cars was a city
silent
a silence where we heard the
rustle of trees
the clattering of horses' hooves
noise of the footsteps of the crowd on the
boulevards and the hubbub of voices in
the silence of the streets and the blackout which
fell in winter around five o'clock
evening and during which the slightest
light at the windows were forbidden
this city seemed absent to itself
the city without a look as they said
Nazi occupants the adults and the
children could disappear from a
moment to another without leaving any
trace
and even between friends we talked half
words and conversations was never
free
because we felt a threat was hovering
in the air in this bad dreams bet
where one might be the victim of a
denunciation and a raf at the exit
a metro station meetings
was between
people who would never have
crossed in peace time love
precarious was born in the shadow of the covers
fire without being sure of
find the next days it's at the
following these meetings often without
next day and sometimes its bad
dating than guys that kids
are fighting etc that's why betting
of occupation has always been for me
like an original night without him I do not
would never have been born this bet there has not stopped
haunt me and his light sees the donuts
sometimes my books here is also the proof
that a writer is marked in a way
indelible by his date of birth and
by his time even though he does not have
participated in a direct way to
political action even if it gives
the impression of being a loner
folded into what's called that all
and if he writes poems they are at
the image of the time he lived and would not
could not be written at another time
so the yeats poem this big
Irish writer whose reading but
always deeply moved the swans
wild
cool ah in a park liszt is watching
signs that slips on the water the 19th
autumn has come down on me since
I counted them for the first time
I saw them before I could finish
account he was rising suddenly and
were laughing while swirling around
circle break on their tumultuous room
but now and slip on the waters
majestic tranquil and full of
beauty by mikel people will do
nor on the bank of what act she
stretches out they have other heavens
when I wake up ray and find a
day they flew the signs
often appear in the poetry of the
19th century in Baudelaire or scheme
the army but this yeats poem would have
could not be written in the 19th century by his
particular rhythm and its melancholy there the
part it belongs to the 20th century and
even the year it was written there
happens even if it happens also that a
21st century writer
shame at times prisoner of his
time and that reading the big ones
novelists of the 19th
safty can not stop
inspires a certain nostalgia
at that time time was running out
in a slower way
today and this slow
to the novelist's work because he could
better focus his energy and his
Warning
since time has accelerated ahead
by jerks
which explains the difference between
large Romanesque massifs from the past to
architectures of cathedrals and
works discontinue fragmented
of today in this perspective
I belong to a generation
intermediate I would be curious
know how the following generations
who are born with the internet the laptop
the males and all express by the
literature this world to which everyone is
permanently connected and where the networks
social partners are starting to share intimacy and
of secret that was still our good
until recently the secret that
gave depth to people
and could be a great romance m
but I want to remain optimistic about
the future of literature
I am convinced that the writers of the
future will ensure succession as
fact that every generation since homer
is by the way a writer like any
another artist may be related to his
time so narrowly that there
not escape and that the solar he
breathe this is called the era of
time he always expresses in his
works something timeless in
stagings of root pieces
or shakespeare
it does not matter if the characters are
dressed in antique lens or that
director wants to dress them up in
blue jeans a leather jacket these are
unimportant details
we forget by reading tolstoy that anna
karenin wears dresses from 1870 when
she is close to us
after a century and a half
and then some writers like edgar
melville poe or stendhal are better
understood in 200 years after their death that
by those who were their contemporaries
ultimately how much exactly
stands with a novelist in the march of the
life to describe it
because if you are immersed in it in
the action you have a confusing image
but this slight distance does not prevent
the identifying power that is the
his vis-à-vis his characters and
those who inspired them in
real life flaubert said madam
bovary it's me and tolstoi c-17
identify right away
the one who had seen him throw himself under
train
a night in a russia station and those
whose identification she is so far
that tolstoy was confused with the sky
and the landscape was describing and who
to absorb everything up to the lighter
anna karenin eyelash beat this
second state is the opposite of the
narcissism because it assumes both a
forgetfulness of oneself and a very strong
concentration in order to be receptive to
every detail
it also presupposes a certain loneliness
it is not a retreat on itself
but it achieves a degree
of attention and 10 pairs of cid
vis-à-vis the outside world for the
transpose into a novel
I always thought that the poet and the
novelist give mystery to beings
who seemed overwhelmed by life
daily to things in appearance
banal and that by dint of observing them
with sustained attention and so
almost hypnotic under their eyes
everyday life ends up wrapping
of mystery and by taking some kind of
phosphorescence that she did not have to
first sight but which were hidden in
depth
it's the role of the poet and the novelist
and the painter also to unveil this
mystery and 7 phosphorescence that
find at the bottom of each person
I think of my distant cousin
the painter amedeo modigliani whose
most moving paintings are those
where he chose as anonymous model
street children and girls
maids of small peasants of young people
apprentices painted them a very acute
reminiscent of the great Tuscan tradition
that of botticelli and painters
Sienese quattrocento he will have to give
well or rather he unveiled the whole
grace and the nobility that was in them
in their humble appearance the work
of the novelist must go in that direction
his imagination far from distorting the
douala reality penetrate deeply and
revealed this reality to itself with
the infrared power of the
ultraviolet light to detect what is
hide behind appearances and I do not
will not be far
in the best case the novelist
is a kind of seers and even of
visionary is also a seismograph
ready to record the movements the
more imperceptible
I always hesitated before reading the
biography of this or that writer
I admired the biographers his task
sometimes to small details to
not always accurate testimonials to
character traits that appear
disconcerting or disappointing and all of that
evokes me it is sizzling which
scramble some radio shows
and make inaudible the music or
the players only reading his
books takes us into intimacy
of a writer and this is where he is at
better of himself and that he speaks to us
in a low voice without his voice being
scrambled by the least parasites but
by reading the biography of a writer on
sometimes discovers a milestone
from his childhood that was like a
matrix of his future work and without
that he always had a clear
consciousness
this milestone event came back under
various forms haunt his books
today I think
alfred hitchcock who was not a
writer but whose films yet the
strength and cohesion of a work
fiction
when his son was 5 years old father
from hitchcock had instructed him to bring
a letter to a friend of hers as serves of
police the child had handed him the
letter and the commissioner had
enclosed in this mesh part of the
police station acting as a cell
and where we keep overnight
most diverse offenders
the terrorized child had been waiting
for an hour before the
Commissioner does not issue it and tell him
if you behave badly in life, you know
now what is waiting for you
this police commissioner who had
really funny principles
of education is undoubtedly at the origin
a climate of suspense and anxiety
that we find in all films
Alfred Hitchcock
I would not bother you with my
personal case is believed only certain
episodes of my childhood served as
matrix to my books later I get
found most of the time away from my
parents are friends to whom he
confided and I did not know anything and
in places and houses that
succeeded on the moment a child does not
is surprised at anything and even if they
find in unusual situations
that's perfectly natural to him
much later than my childhood did
appeared enigmatic and that I tried to
know more about these different
people my parents
had entrusted
and if different places that changed
constantly but I have never managed to
identify most of these people niasse
locate with topographic accuracy
all these places and its houses of the past
this desire to solve riddles
106 really succeed and try to
breaking a mystery gave me the envi
describe as if writing and
the imaginary you help me solve
finally these riddles and its mysteries and
because it's about mystery
I think by an association of ideas at
title of a French novel of the nineteenth
century the mysteries of paris
the big city in this case paris ma
hometown
elie to my first impressions
of childhood and his impressions were so
strong that since I never stopped
explore
the mysteries of Paris it was happening to me
9 or 10 years of walking alone and
despite the fear of losing myself going
further and further into neighborhoods
I did not know on the shore
right of the Seine
it was in daylight and that's me
reassured in early adolescence I
I was striving to overcome my fear and
to venture at night to neighborhoods
even more distant by the subway is
as well as one makes learning of
the city and in that I followed the example
of most novelists that
I admired and for whom since
19th century the big city that she gets
name paris-london saint petersburg
stockholm was the decor is one of
main themes of their edgar books
poe in his new gives crowds a
been one of the first to evoke all
his human waves watching him
behind the windows of a cafe and who is
succeed interminably on the
sidewalks they spot an old man to
the strange appearance and he follows it for
at night in different neighborhoods of
london to know more about him
but the unknown is the man of the crowds
and it is vain to follow him because he
will always remain anonymous and that's it
and there we will never learn anything about him
he does not have an individual existence he
is simply part of this
mass of passers-by walking in rows
tight or jostling and
lose in the streets and I also think
an episode of the poet's youth
thomass of queen is that he scored
forever in london in the crowd
oxford swift
he had bonded with a girl
one of those chance encounters that
we do in a big city they
had spent several days in his
company and he had to leave London
for some time it was agreed
that after a week she
would wait for him every night at the same
hour at the corner of ticheville tweets but
they never found themselves
certainly we have been good
time looking for one another at the same
moment through labyrinth standards
from london may be we did
were separated only by such that m he
do not need more to achieve
an eternal separation for those who
were born having lived as the
years spend each quarter each
street of a city evokes a memory a
meet a sorrow
a moment of happiness is often the same
street is bound for you to memories
successive
so that thanks to the topography of a
city ​​it's all your life that you
returns to memory by layers
successive as if you could
decipher the superimposed scripts of a
palimpsest and also the lives of others
of these thousands and thousands of strangers
crossed in the streets or in the
subway corridors at rush hour
that's how in my youth for
help me write I was trying to find
old betting directories especially those
where denounces are listed by street with
the building numbers I had
page after page printing to have
under the eyes an X-ray of the
city ​​but of a sunken city
like atlantis and breathe the smell
of time because of the years that had
elapsed the only traces that had
left his thousands these thousands
from strangers it was their name their address
and their phone number
sometimes a name disappears it's from a
year to year there was something
dizzying to flip through his old
directories thinking that now the
phone numbers will not answer
later I had to be struck by the
verse of a poem does it mandelstam I
came back to my familiar city
until the sobs until the camp glion of
childhood up to and received journals the
petersburg skin of my phones you have
the numbers Petersburg I have the
addresses of olden days where I recognize the
dead to their voice yes it seems to me that
it is by consulting his old friends
mayor of paris that I wanted
to write my first books
it was enough to point out a pencil the
name of a stranger
his address and his telephone number
and to imagine what had been his life
among these hundreds these hundreds of
thousands of words one can get lost or
disappear in a big city on
can even change identity and live
a new life
we can indulge in a very long
investigation to find traces of
someone starting out with one or
two addresses in a lost neighborhood the
brief indications that appear some
times on the research sheets has
always found an echo at home last
known home
the themes of the disappearance of
the identity of the time that passes are
closely related to the topography of
big cities that's why since the
19th century
they have often been the domain of
novelists and some of the most
great of them we associate are
associated with a city balzac and paris
dickens and london of this gas what is
saint Petersburg tokyo and nagai caf or
stockholm hjalmar soderbergh
I belong to a generation that has suffered
the influences of these novelists and who
wanted to explore what
baudelaire is the most sinuous of
great capitals of course for 50 years
that is to say the time when teenagers
of my age experience very sensations
strong discovering their city
these have changed some in
america and in what was called the
third world became megacities
with disturbing dimensions their
inhabitants are partitioned in
neighborhoods often abandoned and in a
social war climate slums
are more and more numerous and more
in addition to sprawling until the twentieth
century and novelist kept a vision
somehow romantic of the city
not so different from that of dickens or
of baudelaire and that's why
I would like to know how novelists
of the future will evoke these gigantic
urban concentration in works
of fiction
you have the indulgence to refer
about my books at the art of
memory with which its to evoke the
most human destinies
elusive
but this compliment exceeds my person
this particular memory that are trying
to collect some bits of the past
and the few traces left on
land of anonymous and unknown and
it also related to my date of birth
in 1945 to be born in 45 after cities
were destroyed and populations
whole had disappeared no doubt
like those of my age made more
sensitive to the theme of memory and
forgetfulness
it seems to me unfortunately that the
search for lost time can no longer be
do with the strength and frankness of
marcel proust the company he was describing
was still stable a 19th century society
century the memory of proust actually
resurrect the past in its least
details as a living tableau
I have the impression that today
memory is much less safe
of itself and it must struggle without
stops against amnesia and forgetting
the cause of this touch of this mass
forgetfulness that covers everything we fail
to capture only fragments of the past and
interrupted traces of destinies
human fleeing and almost
elusive but it's probably the
vocation of the novelist in front of this
big blank page of oblivion makes you
resurrect a few words half cleared
as these lost haysbert left shores to
the surface of the ocean